[Musique]
comme chaque année les meilleurs élèves
en orthographe se retrouve dans
l'hémicycle du département pour disputer
la finale du championnat régional
sur les trente mille candidats inscrits
au début de la sélection
ils ne sont plus qu'une centaine à
participer à cette 26e édition du
championnat régional d'orthographe
pour être précis il faut être attentif
il faut bien mémoriser les règles
d'accord que ce soit en grammaire
conjugaison
savoir aussi que call ou tel mot qui
commence par tel ou tel son ca ceux qui
comme ça et qu'ils sont plusieurs dans
la même famille
des élèves de cm1 cm2 de 6e 5e 4e et de
3e rédige une dictée extraites du livre
le jardin secret et autres récits de
joëlle brethes j'ai trouvé ce n'est plus
un rapport à l'année dernière
le cdas et le département récompense les
vainqueurs du concours d'orthographe est
également les vainqueurs du concours de
calcul rapide des lauréats qui compte
bien défendre leur titre dès l'année
prochaine ça choquant 11 à l'orthographe
est entré dans les moeurs et on a
toujours beaucoup de participants le
département contribue grandement fait en
sorte que c'est c'est matières nobles
puisse perdurer et puis est intéressé
toujours aller mais où les jeunes et les
enfants
[Musique]